the cost of friends
wow does courtney still have her lines
written on the table
we've literally just slipped right back
[Applause]
we regret we have such a bond from this
show
hbo max just released the official
trailer for the highly anticipated
friends reunion special
and all i got to say is could we be
any more excited look at me i'm chandler
could i be wearing any more clothes
the teaser for friends the reunion
dropped wednesday and features
all your favorite friends jennifer
aniston
courtney cox lisa kudrow matt leblanc
matthew perry and david schwimmer and
they discuss
everything from being cast on the show
the first table read that's the first
time i laid eyes on any of you
everyone was so perfectly cat
i remember i went to the producer of the
show i was on
and he said that show's not gonna make
you a star
to whether or not ross and rachel were
on a break
but if time was what you needed just to
gain a little perspective
[Music]
were ross and rachel on a break yes yes
yes yes
they even threw it back to this iconic
moment
what is monica's biggest pet peeve
animals dressed as humans that's correct
yeah they brought back the trivia game
what do i do with that information now
but no word on whether there's a
lightning round
the test is ready rachel wrote ross a
letter
and demanded he read it before they got
back together
how many pages was that letter 18 pages
18 pages
front and back front and back is correct
and get this there's even a special
appearance from
janice played by maggie wheeler who
served up those three little words
oh my god oh
my god
yeah but she wasn't the only one to read
a few famous one-liners from the show
this is from the one where everyone
finds out
lisa kudrow who played phoebe on the hit
sitcom
shared that gem and gushed over her
co-stars
when i watch the episodes i'm laughing
out loud because you all make me laugh
so hard basically the whole trailer is
just a feel-good
stroll down memory lane where's the
tissue box
no but really where are the tissues
it was an incredible time we became
best friends yep i'm gonna cry now
fans got their first look at the reunion
special which airs thursday may 27
on hbo max last week
the network also released a star-studded
list of special guests that will be
featured
like david beckham justin bieber mindy
kaling
cindy crawford james gordon lady gaga
and bts i'm really excited
former friends guest stars reese
witherspoon and tom selleck will
also make appearances oh my god richard
monica chandler hey hey hey
and it's pretty clear the cast is
excited about it all
the cast is incredibly grateful and
want to give back you know by doing this
special courtney cox recently shared
this video to instagram playing a cover
of the friends theme song
and lisa kudrow told et this last year
i can't wait for it to happen i mean the
six of us haven't been
in a room together in front of people in
25 years
and only once a few years ago just
privately for dinner so
and we had a great time so i can only
imagine it's going to be fun
i mean it'll be really fun
you